for five days Vienna is the place to
head for one-of-a-kind necklaces rings
and brooches jewelry collectors and
makers meet at the Vienna jewelry days
the trade fair starts out with ten
selected artists exhibiting one work
each in the museum for applied art 150
international designers are represented
at the jewelry days here not everything
that glitters is gold initiator
Christina Verner makes out several
trends yet sufficiently we have a lot of
jewelry in the area of upcycling and
recycling for example Mariel outreached
of Germany uses plastic foils to make
brooches when he's finished you can't
tell what material was used and a really
big trend is 3d jewelry and there are a
great many jewelry artists producing
gender-neutral jewelry for instance a
change that can be worn by a man or a
woman deacon and man can also go to try
and buy any flower jewelry can be a
status symbol as much as a fashion
accessory designers seek to elicit a
response to their works
many things don't make a tremendous
impression at first sight but when you
look at them more closely or understand
the humor behind them then they work at
a meta level to kind of meet that even
at you always have people ice cream
which is made of why I like this a lot
with classic forms of jewelry but they
also try to break with them sometimes
ironically so that they throw people for
a loop during the Viennese jewelry days
the artists are showcasing their designs
in various places across the city their
pieces range from necklaces from a 3d
printer to bracelets made from horn
Michelle Berger a jewelry designer from
Germany is taking part in Vienna for the
first time his rings are rather out of
the ordinary
the Canadian smoked jewelry differs from
normal jewelry because even the
slightest movement of the wear sets the
piece in motion so naturally that
attracts attention more than is usually
the case for jewelry doesn't monetize if
I moved off honest Michelle Berger makes
all his pieces and his Dusseldorf studio
the Goldsmith learned his techniques
from Friedrich Becker the inventor of
kinetic jewelry
Michale burger often has to work through
a number of designs and prototypes
before such a piece functions as
intended
[Music]
amenda want our implants the unseen tiny
ball bearings axles and screws or at
work here I never use magnetism even if
many people assume that at first it's
all precision mechanics that has to be
crafted very carefully so that this
floating effect comes about even becomes
Michelle Berger works with coated
stainless steel gold silver and precious
stones his rings cost more than a
thousand euros men and women alike can
wear his jewelry Berger is fascinated by
people's differing perceptions responses
are a bit polarized I have to say some
people say it's great but it would drive
me batty others say it really calms me
down
so people have extremely divergent
responses they definitely respond and
that's positive this is a kind of
jewelry that doesn't leave anyone cold
so I'm quite content because it's not
jewelry for just anybody yeah in
addition to exhibitions the program at
the Vienna jewelry days includes talks
and workshops
doesn't mr. this is a great forum to
present yourself and to meet other
artists and people interested in the
jewelry scene for me exhibiting in
Vienna is something new it's fascinating
to see how the locals respond to my work
his show got off to a good start
the critics at the opening were nothing
if not moved by Michele burgers jewelry
[Music]